So Donald Trump really may not need to steal
this election.
We actually have the latest 538 projection
which says that there's a 71 percent chance
Joe Biden wins and a 29 percent chance Donald
Trump wins.
You might recall those are very similar numbers
to 2016.
And in 2016, of course, it went the way of
the 29 percent.
So we're going to deal with that tomorrow.
But the point is, Trump may not need to steal
the election, but he's not taking any chances
and he's going to try to steal it.
Because why not?
If you can do it, why wouldn't you do it now
without redoing my previous commentary on
the race being closer than these double digit
polling lead suggest?
I'll remind you when Joe Biden is up nine
in a poll with a three point five margin of
error.
That means Joe Biden might only be up to in
the popular vote with the popular vote win
of two point two in 2016.
Hillary lost, so I won't redo the entire commentary.
But but the point is, when we see these leads
for Joe Biden, we just we really have to assume
nothing.
And in fact, the 538 forecast, which I'll
go over in detail with you tomorrow, supports
this very, very closely.
But what we should know is this is going to
be an election that if Trump can steal it,
he's going to try to steal it.
And we need to understand all of the ways
in which he's going to try to do that.
Up first of all, Donald Trump has been saying,
oh, this is going to be an unfair election.
He's trying to make it unfair.
Donald Trump has been saying this election
will be rigged.
Well, he's the one trying to rig it.
Trump has been saying vote by mail won't be
reliable.
He's the one trying to make it unreliable
by kneecapping the post office.
And Ryan Cooper wrote a good piece this week
in the week in the publication The Week called
Donald Trump is trying to steal the election.
And he outlines the various tactics and strategies
and approaches that Donald Trump is employing.
And there's actually a lot of them.
And whether we can fight all of them at once
or how we do it is sort of the next question.
But we've mentioned some of these before,
and I want to put them together in a list.
So, first of all, I mentioned this already.
Donald Trump is trying to break the post office.
The idea is if people are going to vote by
mail, if states are going to expand absentee
ballot access, break the post office so that
it will be less likely to succeed in polls.
We've looked at Trump supporters among those
planning to vote in person.
Two thirds are Trump voters, among those planning
to vote by mail.
Almost three quarters are Biden voters.
So you see right away why Trump would try
to break the post office.
That's one strategy.
Number two, Donald Trump is trying to fine
tune and find time a stimulus, a second stimulus
so that it will be best positioned to essentially
buy votes.
And part of this is that Donald Trump has
said I will defer payroll taxes if he can
write what, we'll see if he can actually do
it.
And if you reelect me, I will make the deferral
a permanent cut.
Okay, so he's effectively saying I will defer
your payroll taxes for now, but unless you
reelect me when you file your taxes next year
for this calendar year 2020, you will owe
the money you saved on the payroll tax.
But if you reelect me, I will make the deferral
a forgiveness if it's trying to buy votes.
The right loves to say, oh, Bernie's trying
to buy votes with free stuff like health care,
which would be paid for through taxes.
This is really trying to buy votes, saying,
I'll defer, I'll save you some money for now.
You're going to owe it back in aped by April
15th of 2021, unless you reelect me.
Okay.
Trying to buy votes.
Number three, Donald Trump is trying to delegitimize
the election to weaponize his followers, taking
to the streets after November 3rd.
And it is working.
We have a new poll which shows that two thirds
of Republican voters now believe that the
election may not be fair.
I'm going to talk about that later in its
own segment because it's so important and
in such a big deal and really is the goal
of all of this.
Donald Trump is using lawsuits to try to turn
the courts.
Remember that the courts, one of the biggest
successes, if you can call it that, one of
the biggest accomplishments of the Trump administration
is mostly thanks to Mitch McConnell's help
getting to Supreme Court justices confirmed,
one of which should have been d'Hondt of Barack
Obama's selection, Merrick Garland and getting
hundreds of lower court judges confirmed.
So Donald Trump is using lawsuits and he's
being open about it.
He's talking about we've got this in court.
We've got that in court.
He's trying to use lawsuits to turn the courts
in his favor after the alleged.
Sean, and to try to prevent vote by mail.
So there's two two sides to this.
Use the courts now to try to block vote by
mail in different states and start laying
the groundwork to if there's a challenge after
the election.
Have courts that maybe will be more predisposed
to rule in Donald Trump's favor.
And you might remember that for a couple weeks
now, Donald Trump has been warning it could
take days.
It could take weeks, it could take months.
Trump even said it could take years to know
who won the November election.
That's not going to happen.
But the point is, Trump is trying to ensure
that it takes longer than it has to.
With the lawsuits, with the destruction of
the postal service, so on and so forth.
Now, again, Trump might not need to do this
stuff.
Trump might be able to win without suppressing
the vote, without turning to fraud.
But it's possible that the only way Trump
can win is with these tactics.
And this very well could end up being the
craziest presidential election that the U.S.
will have ever had, at least in the modern
political era.
So what do we do?
Come on.
You guys know what we do.
You know what we do?
We vote early.
Ideally, they can slow down your ballot.
Trump can slow down your ballot by having
Lewis the joy.
The new postmaster general who is a Trump
donor, restrict overtime so that mail piles
up in post offices.
Look at trying to shut down some postal offices,
post offices or whatever.
But if you mail in your ballot three weeks
early, even if it's slowed down by one, two,
three, four days, it's going to get there.
And presumably, presumably, it's going to
be counted unless Trump figures out a way
to mess with the actual election and voting
precincts themselves.
They can close polling places.
But if you plan to vote early, you will be
less affected by that.
So put the mask on or do the Maylin thing
or whatever.
Let's do this.
We know now that it is Biden and Harris could
not be more different than Trump and Pence
for all of the complaints we might have about
a lack of perfection in this ticket.
And certainly there are many.
And be aware of when and where you can start
to vote early.
I'm going to talk about that a little bit
in the next segment.
But a lot that we
can
do
and a lot that we should be doing,